welcome to this video playing good
movement dr k ok now he is playing let's
see ok mmm not sure I do something else
maybe let's play a different variation
just to get some other some other flavor
on the board ok he just goes with d3 and
very normal stuff but here I get in the
fianchetto maybe am I can play can play
for f5 at some point
yeah interesting it's a little bit of a
little bit different than the normal on
the normal rule dope-ass Spanish and
middle games okay mmm yeah King age
seven is g5 totally totally stupid maybe
maybe it really is okay well f5 is
really opening up my own position maybe
I can still play it he takes Bishop
chicks I mean what I definitely have
going going from years for good
development but okay the CAPTCHA the
caption
can I go f4 here f4 takes pawn takes
bishop moves and then the exchange sack
on age three this is one F on f3 I mean
I can one this is this is crazy but I
like to do something interesting
wrightson I am even ok then eco patch
Danny a kopeck he invented the Copic
opening kopek system probably not
pronouncing it's right in line in the
Sicilian ok so he tries to be tricky
himself
young if i take on their forum 27 my
Scott 92 it's not really really great
how interesting this was maybe it just
good young I mean I can I can take it h3
even
that's really wack yeah but I think it's
smoking his bishop is also hanging low
came and now i go here so this is really
great for white I don't know
interesting maybe I should have gone to
see eight actually but ok to have g four
cameras you know so that Bishop g4 would
be now possible not good but maybe I can
still go g5 and 96-94 this kind of thing
it seems playable
yeah okay I mean I have e5 protected
quite often so I can I can do this
here to f4 or not but that's really the
way to try to justify the whole business
wow really okay well maybe maybe you can
do it why not so that's ambitious but
maybe good take sticks yeah okay I just
I just grabbed him not sure I don't have
have time to really think about it too
long I definitely need to be cautious
about this Bishop here coming okay so i
got Queenie fire very quickly not good
not good
ok
now unfortunately it's got this pressure
going
if I things ah at the end he can take a
five and my whole position is falling
apart ah that's bad now I totally
totally not it's totally lost I Bishop
f4 okay black resigns yeah maybe the
pong crap wasn't so great I know was
very very weird stuff let's let's check
this for a moment he went Queenie too
and maybe maybe I really should go to
see eight but okay I wanted to play a
moment here CCA tests the idea to allow
this pin which is quite nice to have
yeah it's really better it's really
better now after this he needs to worry
about this pin okay so war but I don't
think my position was that bad ready was
still fairly active maybe g4 was
nonsense I really underestimated night
edge form that's really really maybe the
Questor them the point in in question I
can do this for example with with with
something that should be quite okay I
mean this is I have active pieces
nothing going on it should be okay
computer gives me quite an edger
surprisingly but ok it's better yeah
this is really good yeah
Knight a5 is strong it simply as strong
here yeah I'm in huge trouble I'm really
am yeah look he ate but it's it's a huge
action that was really good he played as
well with night edge for g4s bad yeah i
really i really shouldn't do that I
really was under estimating I was just
thinking okay I go here and that was
really not appreciating how strong it is
that the night comes to f5 if you see it
with a bit of time you you pretty much
quickly see okay that light squares are
total disaster after that but I didn't
see that right away well okay he played
as well thanks for watching